you think like oh I think I know what
something is gonna taste like no there's
a weird trending combo going on Pizza
dipped in milk
it started with Gordon Ramsay saying
pineapple shouldn't be on pizza okay
point up on a pizza not pineapple
anywhere which I disagree with and
people started tweeting pizza dipped in
milk saying that it's better than
pineapple pizza I got a bunch of my
co-workers here to try different pizzas
dipped in milk flooding pizzas one of
the greatest things on the planet Earth
who doesn't love pizza right dummies I
love pineapple on pizza
that's stupid the mixture between savory
and sweet don't put fruit on my pizza
unless it's a tomato I love milk so much
I have three different types of milk
here I have almond I have 1% and I have
lactaid milk is basically mucus I like
milk with everything especially bread it
kind of melts to bread in your mouth
soggy what she's looking for because you
don't have to chew as much as like a non
soggy food are you 85 slice of pepperoni
pizza dipped in milk normally when I see
pizza my mouth starts to water and right
now my mouth is dry as the Sahara this
feels so wrong I feel gross already what
the is that it was bad and then it was
good it was like a sine wave mmm maybe
no maybe I feel like it I just don't
understand why I don't taste anything
the flavors cancelled each other out and
now I'm just eating like cardboard it
tastes like you're eating tofu because
it like soaks up the milk
I mean we're both like kind of about to
finish this pizza I'm losing grease to
the milk I'm not happy about it we're
about to try pineapple sausage pizza
dipped in milk mwah
maybe this will make me like pineapple
because I could see how pineapple and
milk would be delicious like that boy I
was about to lie to Caine but I'm
allergic I don't have to eat this shall
we dance yeah let's do it
that was so weird
Oh hold the bones Oh mm-hmm I think we
may have found herself a winner I don't
know what the milk and pineapple are
doing to each other they're not getting
alone at the end it was like sausage
comes punching through our it's sweet
there's so much going on my mouth right
now that one I cry it tastes like a new
food I like ice cream bread yeah I think
I like pineapple pizza with milk without
milk
no the last Pizza we're trying is
supreme pizza dipped in milk there's a
lot of stuff going on olives peppers
sausage mushrooms pepperoni onions it
might be 'wipeys nightmare because she
hates vegetables we're dipping mushroom
and milk think about that for a second
and try not to gag all right oh there's
so many toppings so the milk kind of
like finds little crevices to hide in
and worse than your mouth these like bar
food chunks coming out now milk makes it
all like one flavor it's just too many
textures that is disgusting I don't hate
it though again fruit tastes good with
milk vegetables don't you're making
great points here Oh vomit on a triangle
it's weird but it kind of works it's the
most offensive thing I've put in my
mouth I actually enjoy supreme pizza so
thanks for that came
teens on the internet do weird things
and maybe they're trolling us adults but
you know what teens I like it you know I
went into this because I'm a curious boy
I may have learned something here today
pineapple with milk it's pretty good
deep sigh with milk thumbs up
I would rather dip pizza and milk then
eat pineapple pizza I'm gonna have to go
down ya know that hey I keep getting
like tempted to take a step a milk to
wash down my people and I look and
there's just like a layer of praise the
supreme pizza and milk is almost as bad
as buffalo wings movie with like blue
cheese they both sound like something
you would be served in hell every day
there's Satan whipping up that batch
once again want to do this again
probably not because I'm gonna look like
a psychopath I'm at a pizza party and I
break out the milk and start dipping it
like a madman
absolutely do it alone so late at night
you close the blinds turn up all the
lights maybe light a candle and you dip
your pizza in milk yeah no judgment I
thought it was gonna be intensity I
didn't realize this was going to be an
existential experience